hi all I hope everybody is doing well at
home happy blessed Ramadan to those who
are fasting this year is going to be
different because for most of us we will
be spending all our time at home but
this can actually be a really positive
thing because that means more time with
your family more healthy home-cooked
meals and also more time to do your
workouts so in encouraging all of you to
continue to stay active at home I've put
together a 30 day workout playlist for
you on my youtube channel the link is in
the description box below a lot of you
have also been asking questions such as
how frequent should I workout how long
should my workout session be what type
of exercises to do and when is the best
time to workout so in this video I'm
going to share with you seven tips on
how you can continue to stay active
during Ramadan let's be realistic during
the month of Ramadan your goal is to try
and maintain your current fitness level
and lean muscle tissue so this is not
the time to be trying out new crazy
workouts for those of you who are
already exercising regularly you want to
continue your fitness routine at a lower
intensity and shorter duration to
prevent muscle loss and weight gain you
should not be training at 100% intensity
and then stuffing yourself at night how
many times per week should I work out I
would say aim for at least the minimum
to maintain lean muscle tissue which is
three times per week three times every
alternate day would be ideal but if you
have been exercising very regularly then
of course you can stick to your five to
six times a week routine what you should
be doing is plan your workout this prior
to Ramadan for instance it can be Monday
Wednesday and Friday by planning ahead
and committing to the schedule this
would give you the discipline and ensure
that you complete every workout session
without excuses
next question how long should your
workout session be I would say stick to
at least 20 to 45 minutes per session if
you were to do a slightly more intense
workout such as a hip session then keep
it between 20 to 30 minutes long if it's
a light to moderate exercise such as
holidays or even strength training then
you can even go up to 45 minutes
how intense should your workout be
simply put your Ramadan workout should
be about 30 to 50 percent less intense
than how you would normally work out
outside of Ramadan remember this is not
the time to increase the intensity of
your workouts or to try new crazy
exercises stick to the workout routine
you have been doing and regress by
decreasing the weights number of
repetitions increase the rest time and
you can even choose easier options such
as a normal squat instead of jump squats
the next question is probably what most
of you would want to know when is the
best time to workout well it is
definitely not when you are fasting or
starving only train when you know you
can have food and fluid in your body
training when fasting can be more
harmful than beneficial training when
your body is in starvation and
dehydration can decrease strength and
mathematics significantly a research has
shown that by dehydrating a muscle by as
little as 3 percent can cause a 12
percent loss in strength and that's not
what we want so the best times to
workout are after iftar this is an
excellent time to workout because you
have eaten a small meal and taken in
liquids which can act as a pre-workout
meal however it really depends on how
much time you have between iftar and
prayers if you choose to work out after
iftar then aim for a shorter 20 to 30
minutes session with a slightly higher
intensity after taraweeh prayers if it's
not too late this is also a really great
time because right after your workout
you're able to consume a bigger
post-workout meal this meal is
for muscle recovery muscle growth and
also can help with fat loss and the foot
one is before sajo if you have the
mental discipline to get up really early
in the morning and spit in a workout
session your morning workout can give
you more energy throughout the day drink
plenty of water and you can even have a
small snack 30 minutes prior to
exercising and after your workout be
sure to keep yourself hydrated drink
lots of water and eat a light
nutrient-dense soccer meal to keep you
going through the day another most
frequently asked question what type of
exercises should i do since ramadan is
when you lose muscle tone it is more
important to focus on strength training
/ cardio aim to do strength training
three times a week and if you really
want to fit in a cardio session then
keep it to two days a week in for 20 to
30 minutes session this is to preserve
as much muscle mass as possible and the
final tip is just for the ladies ladies
the best time to workout during Ramadan
and to increase your workout intensity
is that one week break you get if you're
wondering whether should I work out when
I'm on my period well the answer is yes
if you feel absolutely fine then perform
your workout as usual and give it your
100% effort in however you do experience
some a cramp or discomfort then take it
easy and do gentle exercises so remember
to enjoy Ramadan this year use these
guidelines and see what works best for
you and of course make sure your
exercise does not take away the main
focus of Ramadan in the end the focus of
Ramadan is spiritual development I also
have a Ramadan meal plan for those of
you who might be interested to follow
all the links are in my description box
below so have a blessed Ramadan stay
home and stay safe remember to give this
video a thumbs up share this video and
subscribe to my youtube channel for a
lot more home workout videos and also
healthy recipes and I will see you next
time
all the best